hey eric boss here in the new rockstars
blue dungeon and we just got a
new special look they're calling it at
the mandalorian season two and this is
the way to watch it sandwiched between
halves of a football game
i'm gonna do a quick reaction to this
before i dive in deeper in a separate
video to go frame by frame to find all
the details that you might have missed
it looks like it's about a minute long
so let's see what we're working with
here we
go
i need your help i've been quested to
bring this one back to its kind
okay there's a skeleton there
if i can locate other mandalorians they
can guide other
mandalorians got it this is no place for
a child
[Applause]
wherever i go he goes oh whistling birds
we see them
they're out
what's that yeah we got a woo
hear the the theme music there
here we go
the mandalorian new season streaming
october 30th only on disney play
okay okay we're good we're good there's
still no ahsoka tano any of those uh
other mandalorians he referred to but i
guess it's fine she's gonna have uh
she's gonna have a pretty sick entrance
i'm assuming it's gonna blow our minds
that's why they're not spoiling it here
you know i know we're we're hungry for
content but like we
we got to be patient right if there were
other things out in the world right now
we'd be like sure
hold off showing us rosario dustin
that's stupid orange makeup we don't
need to see it right now but
i think we wanted to see it but hey i
got to hand it a day fellow knee to uh
jon favreau
they're really playing this close to the
vest and that's totally fine we still
don't know much more about the plot of
the second season other than that one
line that you might have caught in which
he's going to find
other mandalorians who are those other
mandalorians well
it's probably referring to katie sackoff
playing beau catan this season
previous owner of the dark saber that
moff gideon now has that also could be
referring to
sabine wren who that might be sasha
banks character we saw her briefly in
the hooded forum last trailer couple
interesting details i'm curious to
diving deeper into
for one it looks like we got another
sighting of horatio's sans character
from the pilot episode that blue mithral
which i find interesting because they
are aquatic beings and we know that
they're going to that water covered
planet right
that could be mon cala i don't know that
guy coming back it could be part of that
episode he was paid in uh the mon cala
currency for that deal
and yeah it does kind of look now that
those x-wings are for sure shooting down
mando and chasing him rather than
providing him some kind of friendly
escort
friendly escort is it friendship if
you're paying anyway he crash lands on
this ice planet we get some different
shots of it
i do think more and more that this could
be ilum
the planet that the first order will
later turn into starkiller base but
there
are crystal caves here that contain
kyber crystals i don't think mando
crashed here by accident i think he is
in search of someone maybe this is the
last known location of ahsoka tano this
is a location she's been to before
yeah in the dunes of tatooine it looked
like we spotted a quick skeleton
my first instinct was crate dragon right
but i i don't know it's like about it it
does look like it might have horns like
that could just be like the curved horns
of a bantha it's a desert lots of things
die in it i do love that we
fully see the whistling birds go to town
gor koresh there is like i did not know
this
existed and i am outgunned i mean really
what i think i love most about this
particular trailer is the music i mean
ludwig joranson this guy
can work all kinds of wonders and the
way he weaves in mando's like flute
theme
into the more tactile percussion it just
feels so distinctive to these characters
in this kind of samurai western
but not to john williams these star wars
as much as i love john williams score
there those light motifs started to feel
a little repetitive in sequel trilogy so
the mandalorian's done a really good job
making itself distinct from the rest of
the star wars universe look i get it
it's a lot of familiar shots we've seen
i'm not any less excited for this next
season we're only like two weeks away at
this point so you're watching this video
now but i am eager to do an even further
in-depth frame by frame breakdown
because i think there are
things that are really subtle that are
easy to miss here i think we're gonna be
able to get that out early wednesday
and yeah i think you may have noticed
that new rockstars has kind of gotten
into this pattern of you know since it
takes a bit
of time to break down things to the
level of obsession that we do first
coming out with
one of these reactions just so you can
see our first thoughts and then giving
ourselves some time to
really break things down that's what
we're gonna do episode by episode of
this season we're gonna have our
immediate after show
wookie leaks our mandalorian after show
it's gonna be me and tommy breaking down
the immediate reactions the immediate
questions you have coming out of each
episode followed by
the next day an in-depth breakdown of
all the star wars tie-in easter eggs
that you might have overlooked
so you're getting double the content
double the takes you're gonna love it
i'm so excited about this next season so
be sure to subscribe to new rockstars
hit that notification bell
subscribe to our wikileaks podcast feed
wherever you get your podcasts leave us
a nice rating and review prepare
yourself for some interesting thoughts
and of course
follow me at eavos following rockstars
and socials we'll see you soon
this is away
[Music]
you